hi today i want to talk about learning a
language in one month
um if you enjoyed these videos please
subscribe click on the bell to get
notifications
and by all means join me at link to
learn languages
so we regularly see
blog posts videos where people provide
advice on how to learn a language in a
given period of time one month
one month three months six months
and typically they have a
you know a range of of uh tips and
tricks and hacks that will enable you to
learn a language more quickly
i am skeptical
uh i'm skeptical because i believe
what manfred spitzer said and that is
that the brain will learn the brain is a
learning machine it's a pattern
creating machine but the brain learns
slowly i don't believe that the brain
learns quickly but you can google and
it's interesting to do because
obviously
those of us who are interested in
learning languages we want to see how
other people learn we want to if there
are useful tips and hints then obviously
we want to you know learn from these
people and there are things that work
for some people that don't work for
other people
and you'll see that some of the
suggestions are
you know just get out and talk to people
well it's very difficult to do that if
you don't first have the language in you
you have the more traditionalist person
who says you must get a good grammar
book
and a good dictionary and i don't find
that necessary either because
sure you'll probably get yourself a
grammar book or a starter book and
you'll read through these explanations
and it won't make much sense
yes you have to refer back to
some kind of grammar explanation but you
can do that at any time it's easily
available
via google
and you'll become curious about certain
aspects of the language
after you've had enough exposure to the
language and that's the way we design
link and you can start reading you look
up words you start to gradually explore
and piece together how the language
works then you become curious and you
look up the grammar
some of the other suggestions you know i
noted some of them that yes they
recommend there are a lot of apps out
there duolingo and
link of course and babel and
and busu and
however
the fundamental process is still one
that takes time whether you are using
these apps or not
whether you have a good dictionary or a
good grammar book or not you still have
to have the language come in you
some people suggest you know memory
techniques
again some people if you enjoy you know
memory techniques i must confess that i
don't i'm i'm not prepared to invest the
time in
memory techniques but some people are
because again i i believe that you know
learning some words in isolation even
using memory techniques
is no substitute for this massive
input reading and listening which is
going to allow my brain to gradually
get familiar with the language
some people suggest you you should have
these
measurable goals and realistic goals and
i think that's a good thing but
i've always found that language learning
is something that's driven by your
motivation and some days you're keener
than other days and the idea that you
should decide that every day at 10
o'clock in the morning or six or
whatever that i'm going to do this that
and the other it can be part of a
strategy if you're that way inclined
it's not a condition and i don't think
it's necessarily going to move you
faster to this goal of of learning the
language in one month or three months
uh
one of the uh suggestions was that you
know you can actually
jump from
v1 on the european framework to c2 by
doing this that or the other you don't
jump in language learning you certainly
don't jump from b1 to c2 because
actually that's a long long way and
that's like almost i would say years
to be c2 you have to be living where the
language is spoken you have to be using
it a lot you have to have done a lot of
reading you have to have put in a lot of
time over a long period of time you
can't just jump because you start
speaking if you don't have the
vocabulary and you don't have a
comprehension you aren't going to jump
to
sort of beyond fluency as it was
described
of course we have things available to us
today we can find the tutor online we
can have skype conversations
we can do all of those things
but we can't do those if we don't
understand the language if we don't have
vocabulary
and
obviously the the closer the language is
to one we know the easier it is to learn
but to suggest that one shortcut to
learning more quickly is to find
cognates
cognates are
very similar words in another language
well that works
if you're learning a language which has
a lot of cognates but if you're learning
a language that has no cognates it
doesn't really help very much
generally speaking the more recognizable
vocabulary there is in the new language
the faster you're going to learn
another argument that's put forward is
you know learn the most important 1000
words 500 words learn the important
words up front
in my experience
first of all
having the most important 500 1000 words
is not going to help you
if you get into a genuine meaningful
conversation with someone because the
vocabulary will go well beyond those
words and unfortunately
frequency in vocabulary declines very
very quickly so you're still going to
have to chase those less frequent
vocabulary items at some point if you
want to be genuinely comfortable in the
language and those very frequent words
they're going to show up anyway you
don't really have to focus on learning
those they'll come at you so often if
you're doing a lot of listening and
reading that those are the ones that
will be the easiest to learn you're
still going to have to pursue
the um
you know the less frequently
used
words another thing another thing you
hear is how to sound like a native
i think if we listen a lot if we
are attentive to the language if we are
motivated
to to sort of imitate the natural native
pronunciation we'll get better
but we may not ever sound like a native
and it doesn't matter in fact it's
interesting i was watching a golf
tournament they interviewed this golfer
from mexico i can't remember his name
but he had a spanish accent but he spoke
excellent english sometimes
if you speak very well and you have a
bit of your native accent that almost
gives your
english or whatever language if you're
learning another language a little bit
of charm
whereas on the other hand if you
exaggerate sort of the native twang but
you don't have the the you know
use of words and the control of the
language that would normally match that
level of pronunciation it may not make a
good impression so
i guess what i wanted to say is
you know
in in this idea of studying effectively
make sure you
expose yourself to a lot of the language
let the brain take its time to learn the
language the brain will learn but it
takes time and don't put pressure on
yourself to learn it in one month three
months six months
nor is it even certain what it is you
hope to achieve in one month three
months six months because if it's enough
if it's a new language you have no
concept of of how much there is in that
language and typically you'll discover
the deeper you get into it that there's
just more and more of it there which if
you're enjoying the language
is a delight and and not sort of
something you want to get past as
quickly as possible so there you have it
can you learn a language in a month
i don't think so